[Music]
every week i go to a club
i act like i'm too drunk to stand
[Music]
and every week a nice guy comes over to
see if i'm okay
okay you are so pretty
[Music]
i am a nice guy
[Music]
are you
[Music]
welcome to your weekly ticket
as part of disney's massive programming
announcement last week we learned that
chris evans will star
in a toy story spin-off titled light
year the new film will explore the life
of the man who inspired the toy story
toy buzz lightyear
who was voiced by tim allen in the four
toy story movies
evan shared his excitement over the
project on instagram writing in part
working with pixar is a dream come true
i've been a massive fan of their films
since the very beginning
my team could barely contain their
excitement when they told me that pixar
had a pitch for me
all they said was buzz lightyear as a
part of that same announcement we
learned that patty jenkins will be
making history as the first woman to
ever direct
a star wars film the film titled star
wars rogue squadron will focus on the
rebel alliance fighter pilots
but will be an original story that will
honor everything in the rogue squadron
franchise
jenkins shared the personal meaning
behind the project with her announcement
of the film
i grew up the daughter of a great
fighter pilot and every day i would
wake up and go outside and look up see
my father and his squadron taking off
and their f-4s
roaring across the sky and it was the
most thrilling thing
still i've experienced in my entire life
so when he lost his life in service to
this country
i it ignited a desire to in me to
turn all of that tragedy and thrill
into one day making the greatest fighter
pilot movie of all time
and while promoting her new film wonder
woman 1984
jenkins also told us what she's most
looking forward to with star wars road
squadron i think it's very important to
always
not only aim to make a great film for
whatever
franchise or or medium you're aiming for
but also to have a deep connection for
why you're the right director for it
this is just such a special connection
for me to get to make a film about this
and and also make a star wars film
which i've always loved the idea of
doing
and so you know i just hope to do this i
hope to do something
totally different than what i did here
but with the same equation
make a great try to make a great film
that you really really believe in
and also bring something to the world
with it that that is
that is personal that you're the right
person to do and
and you know all of those things but i'm
so excited
yahya abdul mateen the second will join
jake gyllenhaal in a michael bay
directed thriller titled
ambulance the film which is expected to
begin shooting next month is based on a
2005 dutch thriller by the same name
the story follows two brothers on the
run from the police who steal an
ambulance not knowing it already carried
a female paramedic
and a patient who is in critical
condition asa gonzalez is also set to
star as the paramedic
while the year might be winding down
there's still plenty of films you might
want to keep an eye
out for before 2020 comes to a close of
course there's big christmas day movies
like patty jenkins wonder woman 1984 and
paul w
s anderson's action fantasy film monster
hunter but there's still plenty to check
out
and here to give us a preview of what's
coming to a screen near you this holiday
season
is fandango correspondent nikki novak
how you doing nikki
i'm feeling a little puffy today i'm not
gonna lie you look amazing you're
you're like a holiday prison very
festive we're both very festive we're
both
ready for some holiday movies clearly
yeah absolutely so
let's talk about this big holiday season
release
wonder woman 1984. what can people
expect
well i had a little sneak preview of the
movie and i have to say
that for anybody who loved wonder woman
who loved this first one
this one feels bigger in a way but it
also
still has that beautiful intimate
relationship between
gal gadot and chris pine for anybody who
was like oh are they still gonna have
the same magic
they have it i cried 3.5 times i'm not
going to say whether they were tears of
joy
or of sorrow it's just an epic movie
there's something about wonder woman
and i don't know if you feel the same
way you can't but the first time i saw
it
the hairs on my arm stood up and i just
got emotional and i just weep there's
something about her that i really
connect to and i think most people
connect you and you will feel that
all over again this time around you have
the addition of kristen
wiig who plays cheetah who is phenomenal
in this movie you know i always think of
kristen wiig and i think a lot of us do
as this snl alum she's amazing but when
she
digs her claws into a darker role she is
so
good that she's so good and then pedro
pascal plays another villain in the film
i'll just say that he likes gold
[Laughter]
spoiler i'm going to give away another
great villain i love him in the
mandalorian he's doing some great work
this is just an amazing film patty
jenkins is my personal hero
everybody should watch this film it's of
course always got the great messages of
love and hope
and humanity that's all i'm going to say
love wonder woman 1984 yeah that's great
i was waiting to hear how kristen wiig
was so i'm excited to hear that she's
great in it so yeah that's outstanding
and she wears leg warmers better than
anybody i've ever seen wear leg warmers
by the way
well you haven't seen me wear leg
warmers but what you know
yeah me and kristen wood got beef on leg
warmers so but anyways
so we need to talk about the rest of the
movies this holiday season what what is
your favorite movie coming out this
holiday season
okay this one i absolutely love top
three favorite movies of the year it's
called news of the world it is tom hanks
once again pairing up with paul
greengrass they of course did captain
phillips together
now paul greengrass is best known for
the jason bourne movies he did a bunch
of those
and in this movie tom is once again the
captain now but he is
also a human twitter and the 1800s
version of jason bourne
are you intrigued yes okay
so he plays a war veteran that meets a
little girl and decides to reunite her
with some of her family after her
parents are killed and takes her across
the treacherous texas terrain now
instead of a cool car like jason bourne
had
he has a horse and buggy this is indeed
a western
and he is the baddest guy in the west
but the reason i say he's a human
twitter is he
also brings the news of the world to
people in small towns this is of course
before the internet
and so he was the person that went to
all these towns and told them what was
going on in
the outside world and he's very
opinionated and very charismatic
much like twitter this is absolutely an
epic movie
for anybody who likes the mandalorian it
kind of has that father
the child story and i think this is
tom's best performance
since captain phillips one of the best
of his career
i was stunned by it thought he was
fantastic highly recommend this one
oh wow okay that's all right that's
that's uh that's a good review of it all
right cool well okay let's say that
someone is spending time with their
family this holiday season what's a good
movie that's for
everybody well for somebody who's
spending time with their family or like
me going to be alone on the holidays
because my family's in another country
doesn't matter what age you are
the croods this is the follow up to this
2013 film
it released on video on demand a couple
of weeks ago but i have to say i've
already seen it three times there's such
a re-watchability factor if you've
already seen it but you
if you haven't seen it and you are
looking for a great family movie that
everybody's gonna love
this is it of course the first one
starred ryan reynolds emma stone
nicholas cage catherine keener cloris
leitchman
as this beloved croods family this time
around
they meet this family called the
betterments now the betterments are
played by leslie mann
and peter dinklage and then kelly marie
tran plays their daughter so really
great voice cast i have to say
probably the best voice cast i've ever
heard in a film
but it's the visuals that also got me
the animation is
amazing but the betterments home that
the croods get welcomed into
is like the coolest man cave
female cave you'll ever it's got so many
bells and whistles and it's just
a heartwarming movie it's perfectly
animated
absolutely loved it the most fun i've
had watching a movie all year
oh wow and peter dinklage is unstoppable
he is everywhere right now isn't he yeah
and it's one of those you know sometimes
when you watch an animated movie and you
you you either don't know who the voice
cast is or you know and you kind of
can't place it you really hear
them that you really hear him and leslie
mann
oh my gosh her voice she's got that
really unique voice
everybody's great awesome now what if
we're looking for something a little bit
more
edgy this holiday okay yeah i'm gonna go
from one into the special video
from the croods promising young
woman i am calling this year's
parasite oh wow okay yeah
yes this is emerald fennel who you would
probably know if you love the crown like
i love the crown she plays camilla
parker bowles
in the last season for the crown that
just came out but she also was the
showrunner for season two of killing eve
so you know she can write some edgy
but this one stars carrie mulligan and
if you've heard anything about promising
young woman it's that carrie mulligan
mulligan's getting
all kinds of award season buzz for this
performance but the reason why i say
it's like a parasite
it's got it's very dark very edgy
there's a social message to it
and it's about a promising young woman a
young woman who is
in medical school and then we cut two
years later she's working in a coffee
shop but she has a double life
and i don't want to spoil it i think the
less you know
going into this movie the better but
it's got all of those
moments like i can't believe that this
director just did this to us
in this movie and you have no idea
what's coming and it is
like you said super edgy so that is my
recommendation
whoa this movie is just a whoa awesome i
actually think that's the kind of stuff
i like to throw at my family during the
holiday season
anyway something to make him think all
right well thank you so much nikki uh
where can people find you
people can find me on the fandango
website and they can also find me on all
my socials at nikki novak
awesome it's always great having you
happy holidays happy holidays kale great
to see you too
available to watch at home on friday is
tenet
you've got something not gonna like
time isn't the problem getting out and
alive
is the problem armed with only one word
tenant and fighting for the survival of
the entire world
a protagonist journeys through a
twilight world of international
espionage on a mission that will unfold
in something beyond
real time christopher nolan wrote and
directed the film which stars john david
washington
robert pattinson and elizabeth debicki
and also available to watch at home on
friday
is greenland what is it what's going on
train do you eld cross the highway if
you are carrying this broadcast
seek shelter immediately what do you
think it is
no idea a family fights for survival as
a planet killing comet races to earth
john garrity his estranged wife and
young son make a perilous journey to
their only hope for sanctuary
amid terrifying new accounts of cities
around the world being leveled by the
comet's fragment the garrity's
experience the best and worst in
humanity
as the countdown to global apocalypse
approaches zero their incredible track
culminates in a desperate and last
minute flight to a possible safe haven
the film stars gerard butler morena
bacharan and roger dale floyd
alright well that's it for today but
leave us a comment and let us know which
film you're looking forward to the most
this holiday season
i'm kale and i'll see you next time